[Music]
No Woman No Cry
audiences have embraced wakanda and
black panther
and Chadwick he knew exactly what this
story what these images meant to the
world
we all suffered an incredible loss when
we lost Chadwick Chad was very much our
artistic partner I would spend time with
him just he and I talking about where we
want to see the story go how much he
admired the other characters and the
actors that portrayed him and the
telling of this story you were all able
to honor him together it was really
moving to come back to wakanda and for
us to be able to do it with a sense of
Celebration
there's so much that's happening in this
movie is amazing so many new characters
to explore just seeing the world of
wakanda again and then now we're going
to this whole new world underwater
my name is
a character we were really excited to
portray in the film arguably one of the
oldest comic book characters that there
is the opportunity to to play a
character like this it's a dream he's
the king of an underwater civilization
called talukan
he is regarded as a living God
I need to know if wakanda is an ally or
an enemy
the level of care in creating this story
it is astounding and so it just really
felt like for all of us to give it
everything we have and more I'm just so
grateful and blessed to be a part of
this the actors were filled with emotion
and passion are you queen of
and my entire family is gone
all together we ended up using those
feelings to create something really
special
the action and adventure with the
emotional Stakes so high things are
happening up down and everywhere
I'm so excited about the world being
able to tap into wakanda again
how each character takes on new
challenges and I'm excited about us
honoring Chad
yeah he would want us to just Inspire
the world
[Applause]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
ers
[Music]
the feather servant God
killing him
will risk Eternal War
[Music]
we know what you whispered
show them
cool we are
[Music]
[Music]